de l'efficacité d'entrée à l'image de ce
panier inscrit dans les premières
secondes du match
les berruyères entament la partie avec
du rythme et beaucoup de détermination
face à elle les turcs manque d'adressé
par des tangos extrêmement bien
organisés en défense
la première mi-temps est un long
calvaire pour fenerbahçe est une
démonstration de force pour bourges
34-21 à la polenta ces félins fondé face
on n'a pas été assez agressifs en
défense et on les a laissés marquer et
si on n'a pas su être solide en défense
on ne l'était pas non plus en attaque
alors avec tout ça on n'a pas pu trouver
notre rythme au début du troisième quart
temps
bourges poursuit sur sa lancée les
paniers rentrer les interceptions
s'enchaînent et la défense brille puis
fenerbahçe se réveille à 3 points
notamment
on savait que ça allait être dur que ça
va être très compliqué on connaît
l'équipe de fenerbahçe on connaît leurs
qualités et on sait que c'est jamais
fini jusqu'à la fin c'est jamais fini
et malgré tout on était là on n'a rien
lâché et voilà on n'a pas pris l'eau
revenu à cinq points de bourges à cinq
minutes de la fin du match fenerbahçe et
fait trembler le prado mais les
berruyères tiennent le choc
bien aidé par une céline dumerc décisive
à deux reprises 67 61 score final moi ce
que je retiens c'est qu'on a réussi à
tenir et on a réussit à tenir parce qu
on a été discipliné et
est déterminé en défense soit même si
parfois on a été permis si fort bon
c'est des joueuses de très grande
qualité cd jeux au niveau mondial
international
avec cette victoire bourges entrevoit
les quarts de finale d'euroligue à
confirmer lors des deux derniers